qu'est-ce que ça va nous apporter comme
supplément d'âme le virtuel alors dans
l'avenir et dans ce siècle
le progrès de la civilisation
train de dire que le progrès
l'abstraction et cette abstraction
aujourd'hui c'est la capacité à se
distancer et se mettre hors de soi-même
et vous vous mettez hors de vous-même
pour avoir plus de conscience de
vous-même et donc que j'essaye de dire
c'est que aujourd'hui avec le virtuel
avec le virtuel nous avons une capacité
d'abstraction supplémentaire qui va nous
faire faire progresser en au moins
sens de l'histoire de l'humanité le seul
progrès actuellement ce serait le saut
du tigre dans le passé faire la
révolution c'est remettre en place des
choses très anciennes mais oubliez
celui-là il était pas subversif il
s'appelait Peggy c'était un bon français
alors